Few would have believed that the frail asthmatic little boy who loved to collect
insects would amount to anything special,
much less the youngest and most robust presidents in US history.
Theodore Roosevelt is transformation from sickly child to master of the bully
pulpit and the ultimate symbol of American strength and vitality is an inspiring
story of the power of self determination.
And this week's biographics graphics,
we uncover his story.
Theodore Roosevelt's the future.
26 presidents of the United States was born in New York City on October the 27th
1858 to Theodore Roosevelt,
Sr and Martha,
but luck Roosevelt.
Roosevelt Senio was one of the leading citizens of New York City,
Theodore Junior,
who was known as TD,
was the second child.
So the affluent couple who lived in a luxurious home on Manhattan island,
dd you had a sister banner who was four years older than him,
younger brother values would follow two years later.
And then there was another sister,
Corinne.
Oh yeah,
rafter that TD suffered from asthma from the age of three.
His condition indeed was so bad that he spent much of his early years in bed
unable to attend school,
his parents,
Hud tutors to teach him from home.
Despite his illness,
young TD relished the opportunity to learn one,
see it lands how to read.
He became a voracious devour of books.
He love to fill his mind with tales of central Nordic heroes as king I laugh and
Erik the red.
He was also fascinated with newspaper stories about the exploits of the famous
British explorer,
Dr. David Livingston Td.
He was a dreamer and he filled his mind with dreams of tracking through
unchartered territories and discovering team to tribes.
Young dd showed an unusual curiosity about the natural world.
One day buying a trip to the market.
He came across a dead seal in a book,
just stall.
He was fascinated with the fines and resent daily to study and measure it with a
ruler.
Eventually he managed to take possession of the seal scholars and take his home
where it became the prize exhibit of his Roosevelt's from Museum of natural
history,
which he had sat off in his bedroom from the age of 16 he began filling his
journals with observations about the natural world is mother regularly took him
on trips to the country in order to help alleviate his ass.
Marin's CD made the most of this opportunity to wonder around in such if fish,
insect,
seals and buds that he could analyze and then write about the Roosevelt
children.
They were raised under the norms of Victorian society as members of the upper
class.
They didn't mix with the less wealthy and strict Moore's of decency were
enforced and manners and politeness.
Where of automotives.
Timportance Sunday night was the day for religious observance consisting of
church followed by a quiet contemplation.
Titty hated Sundays is,
this was the day he was not permitted to indulge in his natural curiosity of the
world.
In 1869 when he was 10 years old,
tds family inbox on a tour of Europe for 12 months.
The children were exposed to the great science of England,
Germany,
France,
and Italy.
Yes,
TD.
He was not impressed.
He lays,
wrote,
I call,
nearly hated it,
as did my younger brother and sister.
Practically all the enjoyment we had was an exploring any ruins or mountains
when we get away from our elders and in playing and all different hotels.
When he was 13 DDS father gave him his first shotgun.
He was dismayed to find that he was a terrible shot,
which brought ridicule from his peers what a friend's challenged him.
So you had a billboard in the distance.
He discovered the problem later recalling not only was I able to read the sign,
I couldn't even see the letters.
He was extremely near sighted.
This had never realized it.
After telling his father about the problem,
he was given a pair of eyeglasses he wrote in his diary.
I had no idea how beautiful the world was until I got those spectacles with is
improved.
Eyesight.
Didi was able to become even more obsessive with his nature studies.
Hey,
Don's tax,
a dummy stuffing,
announcing birds that he shot and adding them to is ever expanding natural
history museum.
In the winter of 1870 to 1871 the Roosevelts made of trips in the Mediterranean
visiting Egypt,
the Holyland,
Syria grease and tucking.
Unlike the trip to Europe,
TD love this experience.
He made the most of the opportunity to shoot exotic birds and then stuff them to
take home and add to his collection.
When he was 13 TD was sent off to Maine for a solo trip,
so improve his health on the train journey north.
He found himself in a cabin with some of the teenage boys in these skinny week.
The spectical last matic boy,
they found him easy mock.
They roughed him up,
beefing him bruised and humiliated when he returns home.
He told his father about the incidents.
Roosevelt Sr told his son that he needed to develop as body physically so that
he could defend himself.
A prize fighter was hired in order to teach the boy how to box.
From this point onward TD,
it became obsessed with building his body.
He began lifting weights,
doing calisthenics and running.
He develops a great admiration for those who possess strength and displayed
manly virility.
It was also determined to live what he called the strenuous life.
The Roosevelt's were a family that were driven by goals and afterwards sounding
from that trip to the Middle East.
They set one for the oldest son and that was to gain entry to Harvard College in
just three years.
This was a terrific challenge for young TD.
He had never gone to school and is all,
although was skilled in languages nature in the classics.
He was rather deficient in mathematics.
A special tutor was high and over the next two years he worked hard to improve
his skills.
The hot work get paid often.
In 1875 he passed the Harvard entrance exams for a freshman at Harvard.
The Charles had name of TD which never of done so he took to calling himself
Theodore.
He immediately took to college life involving himself in political parades,
boxing tournaments,
and a rowing competition.
He also became a skilled debate or taking on professors and fellow students
alike to is Deloitte.
He found himself readily accepted and we've seen invited to join some of
Harvard's most prestigious societies,
fatals blissful existence there was interrupted during a visit home in his
sophomore year.
He found that his father was gravely ill with his beloved TD back home.
The old man's health revived some Watson.
The dangers seem to have passed,
but when Theodore returned to Harvard for the new year,
his father took a sharp turn for the worst.
Towards the end of February,
Theodore received a telegram to return home urgently.
He never made it in time.
His father died that very night.
They had all was deeply depressed as a result of his father's death.
However,
he refused to show any of this pain to others instigating a pattern that he
would continue for the rest of his life.
He soldiered on disciplining his mind and body to do what had to be done still
his grief,
and it was evident in his actions.
During a summer vacation to oyster bay.
He rode his horse to exhaustion.
When a dog insisted on chasing the horse,
he turned and he shot it.
They had also began hiking,
finding the release in the great outdoors.
He teamed with a crusty old adventure by the name of Bill Seawall,
who served as his guide.
See,
we'll later recorded his impression of Theodore Roosevelt at the time stating he
was fair minded.
Theodore was zen's.
Then he took pains to learn everything.
That was nothing beneath his notice.
I liked him right off.
I liked him clear though that wasn't a quality in him.
I didn't like.
He wasn't had long or aggressive except when necessary and just far as I could
see,
he wasn't a bit cocky though.
Other folks' thoughts.
So by his mid teens,
Theodore had developed into quite a character,
never afraid to express his opinion.
He could always be counted on to be the center of attention is unique.
Albus it's of approval.
Bully and de Lighters quickly became trademark responses.
In 1879 he set his charms on a young woman by the name of Annesley.
See that girl?
He said,
well,
hell,
vid pal,
she won't have me,
but I'm going to have her and have her.
He did.
He says out on a campaign to win the Ellis' heart leading to their engagements
in early 1880 they had all graduated from Harvard in June of that year,
the 21st and this class of 160 students.
Then in October,
he and Dallas,
we're married,
offer a short honeymoon.
Theodore enrolled in a law degree at Columbia University while also working at
his uncle's law fan.
During his limited leisure time,
he decided to learn about the war of 1812 when we couldn't find a decent book on
the subject.
He decided to write one himself during the summer of 1881 the young couple took
a trip to Europe while in Switzerland's Theodore left his wife behind while he
climbs the matter one.
It was during this trip that he decided to forego a legal career and he was
determined to set his sights on becoming a politician.
Back.
Politics was actually
seen as being beneath men of wealth and various friends tried to dissuade
Theodore's ambitions,
but that was always going to be a losing proposition.
And on returning to New York,
he joined the Republican Party.
Yeah.
He was associating with a class of men that he hadn't previously mixed with
rough men who were skilled in the low blows and dirty tricks of stage politics.
Roosevelt soon learns their ways and within months he had won the party's
nomination for a seat in the New York state assembly.
It was a solid Republican sesions Roosevelt's,
he won it handily,
Roosevelt tens up to take his seat to the New York state capitol in Albany on
January the 22nd 1882 he cut the figure of a dandy with is fine suit and his
upper crust ways.
He was ridiculed by Democrats as well as Republicans.
Despite this,
he,
according to his own recollection,
rose like a rocket ship in New York,
politics,
Roosevelt politics.
They were grounded in self determination.
He firmly believed that each man was in control of his own destiny,
but he also realized that the system,
it was grossly unfair with those with the money and power having all of the
opportunities.
He made it his goal to bring about a fairer assist and were all Americans have
the opportunity to succeed when he wasn't working his way up the political
ladder in New York theater or ventured out west in order to fulfill his love of
adventure and the outdoors.
In September of 1883 he made an excursion to the Dakota badlands with the
express purpose of bringing home a buffalo had as a trophy as with most things
he set his mind to.
He was successful in that goal.
During this trivial also purchased a cattle ranch in November of 1883 Theodore
won his third terms of the New York state assembly.
He returns to Alberni while his wife who was heavily pregnant with their first
child,
went to live with his sister.
On February the 11th 1884 he received a long awaited telegram announcing the
birth of the baby girl.
But this telegram had also told him that Alice was very sick.
He rushed home to discover that the news was even worse,
both his wife and his mother or gravely ill.
They both died on the same day.
February the 14th 1884 that night he wrote in his diary.
The light has gone from my life.
Theodore responded to the double tragedy with the stoicism that epitomized as
personality.
After a few days of isolation be left the baby in the care of his sister and
returned to Albany to see out his time and the general assembly life,
I'm gonna have to go on [inaudible].
Energy for Roosevelt works tirelessly to propel himself from state to national
politics.
His Brash on wavering style brought into the attention of prominent men,
including an influential Bostonian by the name of Henry Cabot Lodge.
By the ends of the year,
the 25 year old was being hired by many as a future Republican leader.
However,
inside Roosevelt was an empty man.
He needed to get away from the rough and tumble of politics in order to heal
himself.
At the end of 1884 Roosevelt retired from politics and moved to one of his
ranches in North Dakota.
Theodore Roosevelt turns up to the small Dakota town of the door addressed in
Buckskins.
He brandished a brand new Winchester rifle as well as a hunting knife that had
bought from Tiffany's jewelers.
He was the quintessential dude and was soon ridiculed by the hardened locals.
Despite this,
he revels in life.
In the West.
He displayed a steely courage,
which impressed all those who came to know him.
Roosevelt hired his old tramping guide bill seewell to come out and manage his
ranch for him,
but he didn't leave all the hard work to his men.
He rode out on the range with them,
chased spooked cattle and stood guard during long and bitterly cold nights.
In 1886 he captured a group of thieves who would start on a boat and then took
them as prisoners on a three day trek to the local sheriff.
During those three days.
He didn't sleep a wink cause he kept his rifle trained on his captives following
the exceptionally harsh winter of 1886 to 1887 which kills half of his cattle
stock,
Roosevelt.
He returned east.
It was 30 pounds heavier than when he left and was a harder,
more confidence fashion of itself.
Soon after resenting,
he matched dolphins.
I fell in love with a childhood friend by the name of Edith Kero.
They were married on December the second 1886 and would go on to have five
children together.
Roosevelt was soon approached by Republican leaders,
urge to reenter politics.
They wanted him to run for mayor of New York.
He accepted and campaigned hard despite having little chance of winning.
He came in third place with 27% of the vote thinking that his political career
was over.
He next put his efforts into writing the book,
the winning of the West.
In 1888 Roosevelt gave stump speeches for Republican presidential candidates.
Benjamin Harrison.
When he won the presidency,
Harrison was persuaded by Theodore's political champion,
Henry Cabot Lodge to appoints the energetic Roosevelt's to the u s a Civil
Service Commission.
He spoke to the role with a vengeance.
Does that mean to find to the curb to spoil system and enforce civil service
doors.
In 1894 Roosevelt was appointed president of the board of New York City Police
Commissioners.
He then set about making improvements,
do these structure of the police force rooting out corruption and imposing more
stringent standards for recruitment.
In 1897 again,
under the urging of Henry Cabot Lodge,
new President William Mckinley appointed Roosevelt as the assistant secretary of
the navy.
He became a strong advocate for the building of the strength of the navy.
When on February the 15th 1898 the u s watershed mean exploded in Havana.
Harbor Roosevelt took it upon himself to order a number of ships.
Do you prepare for war?
When war was declared a short time later,
Roosevelt resigned his post and forms the first US volunteer cavalry regimens.
He was determined to be in the thick of the action.
The
press stubs,
Roosevelt's Cavalry Regiment,
the rough riders.
After a period of training in San Antonio,
Texas,
they were shipped to Cuba.
That first action was at the battle of last quest cmos where they forced the
Spanish to a band and they're entrenched positions.
On July the first 1898 Roosevelt led his men on the famous charge up cattle
hill.
It was the only man on horseback making an easy target for the enemy.
Still without any care for his own safety.
He rode up and down the line [inaudible] man off the hill,
also attempting to take the hill where soldiers of the ninth us cavalry,
but these soldiers were having a hard time of it.
A reporter for the New York Times recorded the action stating Cardinal
Roosevelt's on horseback broke from the woods behind the line of the ninth and
finding it's men buying in his way.
He shouted,
if you do not wish to go forward,
let my men pass please.
The junior officers of the ninth with their negroes instantly sprang into line
with the rough riders since charged at the blue block house on the right.
I speak of Roosevelt first because he was without a doubt the most conspicuous
figure in the charge.
Roosevelt mounted high on horseback and then charging the rifle pits at a gallop
and quiet alone made you feel that you would like to.
Chia,
he wore on his Sombrero I blue Polka dot handkerchief,
which has the advanced floated out straight behind his head like a guide on
having reached the crest of the hill.
Roosevelt dismounted and urged his men to follow him,
but that was yet another hill to conquer and no sooner had the rough riders
scrambled to the top of cattle hill.
Then that dashing carnal set off for San Juan Hill as men overpowered the
Spanish resistance and took possession of both hills in the process.
Roosevelt's killed to Spanish tree bub,
who he said doubled over like a jack rabbits following victory in Cuba,
Roosevelt returned to New York,
right.
It was convinced to run for governor campaigning vigorously on his war record.
He won by just 1% of the popular vote during his time as governor,
he developed the stylings platform,
which would underpin his leisure presidency.
It was a passionate advocate for the rights of the underprivileged was against
large corporations and monopolies and champions.
The preservation of natural resources.
In 1900 Henry Cabot lodge and other prominent Republicans urge Roosevelt's to
throw his hat into the ring for the vacants Republican vice-presidential spot in
the upcoming presidential elections.
Though reluctance,
he won the Republican nomination pairing with President Mckinley with his
boundless energy.
He threw himself into a barn storming campaign,
making 480 speeches in 23 states in the end and Mckinley easily one and Theodore
Roosevelt was sworn in as the vice president of the United States on March the
first 1901 six months later,
President Mckinley was shot while attending the Pan American exposition in New
York.
He died eight days later as a result of the 42 year old Roosevelt who was
propelled into the highest office in the lands becoming the 26th president of
the United States on September the 14th 1901 he was the youngest man to ever
hold the position.
Roosevelt was very different man to William Mckinley still valid and that he
would continue to pursue with the policies of his predecessor.
At the same time,
he was determined to do stamp his mark on the presidency in order to win a
second term in his own right.
A large part of the focus of Roosevelt's domestic policies were focused on
breaking up the monopolies of big business.
He instituted 44 antitrust suits forcing the breaking up of the Northern
Securities Company and putting regulatory controls on standard oil of all the
domestic policies that Roosevelt was passionate about.
However,
none came close to the preservation of wildlife than the environments he
established.
The United States forest service created five national parks and place to total
of 230 million acres of lands under public protection.
In terms of foreign policy,
Roosevelt,
he was an ardent imperialists.
He successfully mediated the treaty of Portsmouth,
which brought an end to the Russian Japanese war winning a Nobel peace prize for
his efforts.
It was making a deal with the Panamanian government for the building of a canal
led to the separation of Panama from Columbia in 1903 and the 1904 presidential
election,
the Democrats put up Alton Brooks Parker to face off against Roosevelt
campaigning on the promise to give every American a square deal.
Roosevelt one that 56% of the popular vote along with 336 of 476 electorial
votes during a second time and office Roosevelt and began moving to the left of
his Republican base,
the Bush for a number of pretty radical reforms including the eight hour
workday,
most of which they were defeated in the house.
He had Declan's that he would not seek a third term and so he became a lame
duck.
Presidents while thought early in drawing the role of presidents,
he fells staying in office for more than two terms would run the risk of
dictatorship
following the end of his second term in office.
In March of 1909 Roosevelt went on an African safari with a group of prominent
scientists and hunters.
The expedition was on behalf of the Smithsonian Institute and was charged with
bringing back specimens for the institutes museums.
The trip was successful in the group,
came back with 11,400 specimens ranging from insects to elephants.
When he returned to the United States,
Roosevelt was far from happy with the performance of his successor,
William Taft,
to believing that Taft has made the Republican's far too conservative.
He began to speak loudly of leading a program of new nationalism which emphasize
Labor over capital.
By the time that the 1912 presidential election rolled around,
Roosevelt was convinced that only he could save the Republican Party.
He challenge Taft in the Republican primary.
However,
the Taft won.
The nomination is squeezing Roosevelt to the sidelines.
Undeterred Roosevelt quit the Republican's forming his own party,
the progressive's,
and he ran for president as an independence.
He then went to the stumps and appealed to the people.
On October the 14th 1912 Roosevelt was giving a speech in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin when he was struck by an assassin's bullet.
This shot was a perfect shot to the heart and it penetrated his breast pocket
and slammed into a thick glasses case.
The bullets then thumped into a heavy speech.
Manuscripts that he had chosen not to use without missing a beat,
Roosevelt ensured that the would be killer was apprehended.
Then he went right on with his speech,
the first word,
so the crowd after being headwear.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I don't know whether you're fully understands that I have just been shot,
but it takes more than that to kill a bull loose.
The bullet stayed in Roosevelt's pectoral muscle until his death,
the 1912 presidential election.
It was won by the Democratic candidate Woodrow Wilson with 42% of the popular
vote.
However,
Roosevelt did to beat the incumbent presidents with 27% compared to 23% for Taft
during a South American expedition.
In 1913 to 1914 Roosevelt contracted tropical fever after suffering a leg wound,
which became badly infected by the time he resides in New York,
he was 50 pounds lighter and deathly Pale.
The last few years were racked with pain for the ones robust outdoor adventurer,
malaria bounce,
where common as where complications of his leg inflammation.
The end came in the very early morning hours of January the sixth 1919 after he
had complained about not being able to breathe the night before the doctor was
summons and after some treatments he felt better.
However,
he died in his sleep as a result of a blood clot in the lungs.
When he heard of his father's demise,
his oldest son,
Archibald's telegraphed,
has siblings with the words the old lion is dead.
It'll Roosevelt.
It was 60 years old.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times a week.
And if you're looking for something else,
why not check out some of our videos from the archive?
But I'm thinking too on the screen now and it was always,
thank you for watching.